after president Xi Jinping delivered a
landmark speech to China's 20th party
Congress the U.S listed Chinese stocks
fell to their lowest level in almost a
decade that's because investors were
reading between the lines of the
president's speech and it could mean the
country's changing in ways that will
make it less profitable and more risky
for foreigners to invest in I'm going to
explain the changes that China is
undergoing how they have already
impacted U.S and Global Investors and
what this could mean for the future of
investing in the world's second largest
economy let's get into it the default of
Chinese property Behemoth ever Grand the
collapse of Tech Giant stock prices and
economic growth that is at the slowest
Pace in decades these are all signs that
China's government leaders are changing
the way the country does business
Chinese Communist Party leaders have put
in place new rules that restrict
borrowing and roll back the growth first
policies that have defined the country
for decades at the national CCP Congress
president XI laid out the vision for
China's latest economic imperative
[Music]
it shuns what she calls the fictitious
growth of financial markets real estate
and gaming in favor of promoting real
growth things like manufacturing
semiconductors and electric vehicles the
idea is not only that China should take
a different approach to growth but that
slower growth is okay and maybe even
desired China made a big deal for years
about changing its markets to be more
welcoming to foreign investors
and in their early days companies like
evergrand and Alibaba were pumped up by
government money and connections but as
China's economy is sputtered not only
has the government not stepped in to
help it is actively made things harder
with strict regulation and harsh
penalties this is a very different
environment than U.S and Global
Investors are used to and we're already
seeing the Fallout China's currency the
Yuan has fallen to nearly its weakest
value versus the dollar since 2007 with
little pushback from its Central Bank
foreign investors have sold out of
Chinese bonds worth hundreds of billions
if you want and major Chinese companies
like Alibaba tencent and Baidu have seen
their valuations plummet here's the big
picture U.S investors have come to
expect that companies will seek growth
at all costs that's how stock prices
rise and investors get paid but China's
new stance appears to be that growth is
secondary what matters is that companies
increase the whole country's wealth and
serve the government's interests that's
not how things work in the United States
or most other places where investors are
putting their money that could put
foreign investors at odds with the
government and in a country with as much
government control as China
that's a hard battle for investors to
win a lot of China's foreign investors
are probably feeling like the greatest
rapper of all time Tupac Shakur who said
I'd love to go back to when we played as
kids but things change that's the way it
is
that's all for now see you next time